Republican and Democratic campaigns
across the country are focusing on
what's at stake in the midterm elections
Nancy Cordes is watching the battle for
Congress and important campaigns for
governor Nancy good morning good morning
well at this point just a few days away
from Election Day the candidates are
moving it to get out the vote mode and
it always helps to have some well known
allies make that case with you and for
you so we're seeing some familiar faces
out on the campaign trail some who spend
a lot of time stumping and some who
don't heading into the home stretch if
we need Ohio to vote both parties are
bringing out their big stars this
election on Tuesday happens to be the
most important midterm election in
Georgia crowds lined up for Friday
tickets to see former President Obama
who's been stumping for Democrats
nationwide but to do it he'll campaign
next for Stacey Abrams Georgia's
Democratic candidate for governor she's
locked in a tight race with Republican
Brian Kemp Abrams he is vying to become
the nation's first black female governor
is also getting some help from the
entertainment industry rapper common
rallied with her at early voting events
this is our time right now to change the
trajectory media mogul Oprah Winfrey
will do two town hall events with Abrams
today and knock on voters doors Kemp
meanwhile campaigned with Florida
Senator Marco Rubio earlier this week
and will appear today with Vice
President Mike Pence this is not a
typical Democratic candidate that we've
seen in the past this is someone as a
radical you know very far left agenda
and be fun being supported by people to
have a radical agenda as well when Oprah
heads to Georgia today this will be just
the second time she has publicly
campaigned for a major candidate the
first was when she spoke on behalf of
Barack Obama during his 2008
presidential bid we should note Oprah
has
been a part-time CBS News contributor
for 60 minutes but she is stepping away
from that role while she campaigns John
all right Nancy quarters Thank You Nancy